Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, you are going to see how one area
of research can unlock new capabilities
on a seemingly completely different area. We
are now living the advent of amazing AI-based
language models. For instance, OpenAI’s GPT-3
technique is capable of all kinds of wizardry,
for instance, finishing our sentences, or creating
plots, spreadsheets, mathematical formulae,
and many other things. While their Dall-E 2 AI is
capable of generating incredible quality images
from our written descriptions. Even if
they are too specific. Way too specific.
Now note that all this wizardry is possible as
long as we are dealing with text and images.
But how about, endowing a real
robot, moving around in the real
world with this kind of understanding of
language. I wonder what that could do?
Well, check this out! Scenario 1. This little
robot it uses GPT-3 and other language models,
and it not only understands it, but it
can also use this knowledge to help us.
Don’t believe it? Have a look. For instance,
we can tell it that we spilled the coke,
and ask it how it can help us out? And,
it recommends finding the coke can,
picking it up, going to the trash can,
throwing it out, and bringing us a sponge.
Yes, we will have to do the rest of it ourselves,
but still, wow, good job, little robot.
Now the key here is that it not only understands
what we are asking, propose how to help, but,
hold on to your papers, because here comes
Scenario 2. Oh my! It also looks around,
locates the most important objects required,
and now, it knows enough to make recommendations
as to what to do. And of course, not all of
these make sense. Look at that! It can say that
it is very sorry about the mess. Well, thank
you for the emotional support, little robot,
but we also need a little physical help
here. Oh yes, that’s better. And now, look,
it uses its eyes to look around, yes, I have my
hand, well, does it work? Yes it does, great, now,
coke can, trash can, sponge. Hmm…it’s
time to make a cunning plan. Perfect!
And, it can also do plenty more. For instance,
if we’ve been reading research papers all day
and we feel a little tired, if we tell
it, it can bring us a water bottle,
hand it to us, and can even bring us an apple.
Now I’d love to see this…be gentle, and! Oh
my! Thank you so much! The amenities at Google
HQ seem to have leveled up to the next level.
And, believe it or not, these were
just really simple things, it can do
way better. Look. This is a plan that
requires planning 16 steps ahead,
and it does not get stuck, and doesn’t mess
up too badly anywhere. This one is as close
to a personal butler as it gets. Absolutely
incredible. These are finally real robots that
can help us with real tasks in the real
world. So cool! What a time to be alive!
Now, this is a truly amazing paper, but
make no mistake, not even this is perfect.
For instance, the success rate for the planning is
about 70%, and it can properly execute the plans
most of the time, but clearly, not all
the time. The longer term planning results
may also need to be a bit cherry-picked to
get a good one. It doesn’t always succeed.
Also, note that all this is played at
10x speed, so, it takes a while. Clearly,
typing the message and waiting for the robot
still takes longer than just doing the work.
However, this is an excellent opportunity
for us to apply the First Law Of Papers,
which says, that research is a process. Do not
look at where we are, look at where we will be
two more papers down the line. If OpenAI’s image
generator AI, DALL-E looked like this, and just
a year and a paper later, it looks like this.
Well, just imagine what this will be able to do
just a couple more papers down the line.
And, what do you think? Does this get
your mind going? If you have ideas for cool
applications, let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!